It's actually quite straightforward
to make your apps content provider
available to third party apps.
The key is to modify the export flag
in the manifest entry here to "true".
As simple as that.
Any app that knows the content URI,
can use the content resolve
would access it
the same way that you do.
Now depending on
the sensitivity of your data,
you may want to protect it
by requiring specific permissions
to read or write to the database.
So if you want to, you can
effectively limit access
only to other apps you've created,
or to third party apps
which know the permissions
and users agree to.
Then you just need
to publish this contract
to interact with the content provider,
specifically the URI and column names.
And you've created a simple API
for all of your data.
And as simple as that,
you've created a new API,
just for your data.
This is exactly the same approach
used by many of the
native content providers,
including the Contacts Database,
Media Store, Calendar and Call Log.